Hello.
I just wanted to make a
quick video to introduce you
to what is probably or what
is definitely the biggest
change that we've ever made
in the history of the Khan
Academy.
We've introduced a
new learning flow
that tries to
engage people more.
We've heard from a lot
of users that there's
a lot of content
on Khan Academy.
They didn't know where to start.
They didn't know what level
was appropriate for them.
And so we've spent a lot of
time thinking about this,
and what you're about to see
is our new learning flow.
So I'm a new user,
and it gives us
a nice little welcome message.
And I say, cool.
Let's explore.
So when you log in,
you'll see this mission--
The World of Math.
And right now as we launch
that is the only mission
that we have.
And it will essentially
walk through all of the math
exercises that we
have on Khan Academy.
Over the next few
months, you're going
to see other missions--
missions aligned
to grade levels,
to preparing for a test,
missions aligned to being
able to do some
type of a project.
You'll also start to see
missions in other subjects.
Now these squares that you
see-- This is, for those of you
who are familiar with
our Knowledge Map,
you can kind of view it
as a condensed Knowledge
Map for the particular mission
that you're thinking about.
So here there are 482 boxes.
Each of these
represents a skill.
It represents a type
of math problem.
So what we're going
to start right now--
and I highly recommend
you do this as well,
it's actually kind
of fun-- is we're
going to start with a pretest.
This is to address
the issue of where
do I start on Khan Academy.
What are the exercises that
are most appropriate for me?
So I'm going to actually
take this pretest right now.
So let's start the pretest.
So if I see anything that is
completely daunting to me,
I should just say, "I
haven't learned this yet."
"What is the area
of the rectangle?"
Well that's just going
to be 3 times 9, which
is 27 square inches.
Well, let's just say for
the sake of argument,
let's pretend that we haven't
learned algebra or geometry
yet, so I haven't
learned this yet.
I haven't learned this yet.
And this is an
adaptive test here.
If I answer
questions right, it's
going to get harder or go
to more advanced topics.
If I get questions
wrong, it's going
to give us simpler
or more basic topics.
Move the orange dot to 4/3.
So 4/3-- that's 1/3,
2/3, 3/3, and 4/3.
Submit my answer.
And I have to do
five more problems.
So this isn't too
long of a thing here.
So similar triangles--
well I said
I'm going to pretend like I
haven't taken geometry yet,
so I'm going to say I
haven't learned this.
Now they gave us a
proportion, 9 over 2
is equal to what over 18.
Well, we multiply
the denominator by 9,
so we have to multiply
the numerator by 9.
So it's going to 9 times
9 is 81, and there we go.
I've done my pretest.
And now the system
is actually building
a model for what I likely know
and what I likely don't know.
And we'll look at
that in a second.
So now you see that some of
these tiles changed colors.
Gray means that I haven't
even practiced this thing yet,
while blue means that I've shown
that the system thinks that I
might know that at
a reasonable level.
And the deeper the
darkness of the blue,
the better that I
actually know that.
So let's actually
start looking at these.
So you can see here that I can
go on each of the concepts,
and it says I'm Practiced
for congruent segments.
It says right here
Need Practice,
or it hasn't started for
points, lines, and planes.
And if you click on
any one of these,
you can go directly
to that exercise.
So based on how I
did the pretest,
it immediately figured out
what I probably know well,
what I might not know that well.
And now this is key.
Instead of having
the old Khan Academy
where you just had this huge
Knowledge Map, and you said,
oh, I guess I'll work on
something-- one of these 500
things that I see
in front of me.
This now will recommend what
the next best thing is for me.
So let me see.
So Reading tables 2, so I
can start working on that.
The table below shows solar
panel installations by state
during the last fiscal year,
except one entry is missing.
So this entry is missing.
And if I'm completely confused
by this-- I've never seen it--
we have a video right
here that should hopefully
help explain that concept.
Let me go over here.
And it says for this one I
have to get five in a row.
And if I get five
in a row, I'm going
to get to that Practiced state.
So, I will just
continue touring.
But I don't have to
do exactly this one.
This is what the
system recommends
the most, is the
next best thing.
But then there's
other things that it
thinks I should also be
working on right now.
So say finding absolute values.
What is the absolute
value of negative 6.5?
Well that's 6.5.
Likewise, we still
have videos there,
and I got one out
of my five correct.
And if you have a coach or
if you are someone's coach,
the coach can also make
their own recommendations.
Obviously we have a
lot of coach tools
so that a coach can
keep track of what
a student is working on.
And then based on
that, the coach
can recommend particular
exercises to be focused on
or to be prioritized.
Now once you've spent
some time on the system,
your Learning Dashboard
might look a little bit more
like this.
And to get closer and
closer to Mastery--
to get deeper and deeper
shades of blue there--
not only do you need to
practice it-- get five in a row
and that sometimes might change
depending on the exercise--
but later on you need
to show that you still
know how to do
that thing in a mix
of many, many, many
different types of problems.
And the place that happens
is right over here,
which we call our
Mastery Challenge.
This is the tool that you want
to use repeatedly in order
to get those squares
as dark as possible.
So let me take a
Mastery Challenge.
Negative 7 minus 3i.
It'd be the absolute value of 5.
Well, that's just 5.
Is this triangle equilateral,
isosceles, or scalene?
So it is definitely isosceles.
If it was equilateral,
these would be 60 degrees.
So it is isosceles.
You have two common base angles.
So you see it's
going through all
of the different
types of mathematics
to make sure that not
only have I remembered how
to do these, not
only have I retained
the understanding
of these concepts,
but I also can do it
in a mixed environment
where I have to also
recognize, hey, what
is a tool I need
to use right now.
What are the factors of 18?
So let's see.
We could have 1.
We could have 2, 3.
Let's see, 4 isn't divisible.
5 isn't divisible.
6 is.
9 is, and 18.
And I could have
used this little tool
to help me with that, but
if you know the factors
you can just type them in.
So let's check our answer.
Plot 10 comma 6 and
select the quadrant
in which the point lies.
10 comma 6, and that's
sitting in the first quadrant.
Move the orange dot to
negative 3 minus 2i.
Negative 3 minus 2i.
And now I'm completing
my Mastery Challenge,
and I'm going to get essentially
a report for what did I
achieve by completing
this Mastery Challenge.
And it's showing us the
things that have gotten darker
based on the fact
that these are things
that I had practiced
in the past.
But in this last
eight problems, I
showed that I still
remembered them.
And I could do it
in a situation where
I'm getting a whole
mix of problems.
And so it's our hope that you
enjoy this as much as I just
did, that this
learning flow really
makes sure that you
know where to start,
that you're starting on
things that are at your level.
And not only are you
learning new things,
but you have an opportunity
to review those new things,
and you have an
opportunity to make sure
that you know when to use
those things when you're
faced with a whole
mix of problems.
So I look forward to seeing how
you can fill out your Knowledge
Map here, fill out
all of these skills,
and fulfill your mission
in the world of math,
and in the future,
other missions.
And we really want
to hear from you
to figure out how we can make
this entire experience better.
So I encourage you go down
to the bottom of these pages
and say Give Feedback.
And tell us what you think.
Tell us what's working for you,
what's not working for you.
And if you have ideas for things
that might make it even better,
let us know.